talk to your leader about whether this
is now something labour can support well
of course we haven't yet seen the detail
Dermot the government will only
published a bill on Wednesday but there
is a broad acceptance that a new law is
now needed the online world has created
blind spots where the authorities can't
see anymore this isn't just about
counterterrorism it's about child sexual
exploitation fraud there is a need for a
new legal framework so they can do their
job the police and the security services
and keep us safe but of course that has
to be balanced by legitimate concerns
about security about sorry liberty and
privacy and my job is to make sure the
government gets that balance right and
so what I can do at this stage is make
sure the debate is is calm and measured
and that is what I'm going to do it okay
I'm not going to play politics with this
issue we need to get a legal framework
that is ready for the digital age and
I'll be working hard to hold the
government to account but crucially to
get that balance right and fair enough
you want to see the bill itself but you
know I phrase that question by saying if
you talk to the leader about it because
of the fluid nature of policymaking at
the moment within the party are you and
Jeremy Corbyn because it is so important
as you point out are you going to be
singing from the same hymn sheet on this
of course I've spoken to Jeremy about it
and the approach that I'm outlining to
you today is the approach that I've
outlined to him witches that Labour
should accept the need for a new law we
will wait to see what that what that law
is we should approach this in a
constructive way because it's in the
country's interest that we have a modern
law to give the police and the security
services the powers that they need but
labour should insist on strong
safeguards to protect people's and
privacy and their liberties now you
began by saying them that the government
had agreed that judges would have
oversight that that isn't what the Home
Secretary is saying this morning she's
yet to make clear whether it will be up
on
titian or a judge who signs off these
requests I am saying quite clearly we
should accept the recommendations of the
Anderson report the government's
independent reviewer of counterterrorism
legislation and we should ensure that
judges have the final say on the most
intrusive warrants and how our relations
between you and mr. Gorman at the moment
of course there was some pretty heavy
pounding between you and all that the
contenders during the course of the the
leadership campaign and he's just got
this relatively new head of policy has
me Andrew Fisher who tweeted about you
and your colleagues who were on Ed
Miliband's front bench that you were the
most abject collection of complete and I
can't say the other word but something
to do with or j means you think some of
his appointments going a bit far though
relations are good to answer your
question I got on well with Jeremy on a
personal level or through the leadership
contest and you will recall that I was
the candidate who said I would work with
him and that is exactly what i am doing
i made a commitment to the labour party
to work hard for unity and that is what
i am doing and I hope that leadership is
followed by people across the rest of
the party the job now is not to carry on
arguing internally the job is to hold an
arrogant government to account and i
think the Labour Party has done that
very successfully Dermot over tax
credits and we should go from there and
carry on you know the public don't want
to see labour arguing internally and
putting our own issues above their
issues they want to see a strong
effective opposition and that's what I
would say to all of my colleagues that
the time has come to do that to turn
outwards and take on the government well
what are you going to do about tax
credits we've seen Scottish Labour now
making it very clear that anything that
cut will be restored it is that's going
to be the policy of the National the
uk-wide Labour Party is that something
you'd like to see well I was very clear
that I didn't want to see it cuts to tax
credits you know this is working people
being hit and actually let's remember
them before the election the government
said it wasn't going to cut them so I
don't believe they've got a man
date to do what they have been trying to
do we'll we'll see what they bring
forward later this month but you know
labor should be very strong and
supporting at working people you know
why should we be having a tax cut for
millionaires and inheritance tax cut
when people are losing their tax credits
of course we shouldn't have that and
that's why I'm pretty proud actually of
the case that labor has made to defend
working people to defend families who
are struggling to make ends meet and
that is exactly where our focus should
be going forward and no doubt you'll be
keeping an eye not so very far away from
where you are now the old and by
election is coming up and we believe we
know that the issue of migration of
immigration is going to loom pretty
large during the course of that campaign
your immigration policy Labour's
immigration policy no got Jeremy Corbyn
not mentioning at all in his speech to
the Labour Party conference but he said
that mass migration is not necessarily a
problem do you have any differences with
him on that well immigration policy is
my responsibility and I did mention it
in my conference speech and I laid out a
very detailed approach where I said we
need to reframe the debate about
immigration in areas like mine there is
a concern the issues around the
undercutting of wages have basically
been ignored by Westminster and because
of that you could argue the EU migration
has widened inequality it's held wages
down and some of the poorer parts of the
country but as fueled growth in the big
cities and I'm saying we need changes to
the European rules to deal with that so
I'm saying let's have protection for the
wages of the skilled workforce let's not
allow their wages to be undercut by EU
migration i'll be going to brussels
quite soon to argue for that because i
strongly believe strongly believe that
britain's place is within Europe and to
remain there but if we're to carry that
argument Europe needs to work for
everybody it needs to be a social Europe
at people's Europe so so you can't agree
with this statement then from Jeremy
Corbyn I don't think immigration as such
has been anything but a plus to our
economic
development well overall it is a plus
isn't it to our economy and to our
society people are people are far more
likely to be treated by an immigrant in
the NHS than to stand in a queue behind
one you know there is so much
misinformation put out there about
immigration overall migrants make a net
contribution to our to our economy so
these facts need to be remembered when
conducting this debate but issues do
arise on the undercutting of wages as
I've just said but also pressure on
public services rapid EU migration can
place pressure on primary schools and GP
services and that's the other point I'm
be I will be putting to Europe places
that suffer the biggest changes or
experience the biggest changes should
get more help to relieve pressure on
their public services so let's have some
practical changes to make free movement
work better for everybody but once we
get those changes dermot we we should
make the strongest possible case to
secure Britain's place in Europe